le climat social s'alourdit la
coordination des infirmières dit non aux
propositions d'augmentation du
gouvernement le ministre de la santé
monsieur claude evin en direct dans ce
journal référendum sur la nouvelle
calédonie le rpr se prononce pour
l'abstention et invente une nouvelle
expression politique la
non-participation motivée et engagée
alain prost le plus grand pilote
automobile français toujours en piste
pour le titre de champion du monde 88
publie déjà ses mémoires
alain prost est notre invité ce soir
nous retrouverons à la fin de cette
édition
voilà monsieur bonsoir le climat social
en france et loin de se détendre en
cette fin de semaine avant les arrêts de
travail prévus la semaine prochaine avec
le point culminant la grève de la
fonction publique jeudi 20 octobre ce
sont les infirmières qui regroupait au
sein de leur coordination en marge des
syndicats donc on aujourd'hui dînions
aux propositions d'augmentation moyenne
de 8% faite par le gouvernement est
reconduit leur grève
françois le jeu les propositions de
monsieur et 20
nous sommes bons mois à l'unanimité
moins deux abstentions
elles ont dit non aux propositions du
ministre de la santé que des vingt trois
heures plus tard à 16h30
assemblée générale de la coordination
des infirmières voter massivement la
reconduction de la grève jusqu'à
satisfaction de leurs revendications
et si la revalorisation de leurs
salaires restent au centre du conflit
les infirmières insiste aujourd'hui pour
qu'un véritable effort soit fait sur
leurs conditions de travail sur les
effectifs et la reconnaissance de leur
profession
ce pack l'amour
c'est vraiment pas clair alors on
voudrait vraiment que ce soit
noir sur blanc rien n'est pris en
considération il ya des gens qui ont des
licences
bon ils ont un certain statut on demande
simplement que notre position notre
statut soit au fort reconnu en tant que
tel en tant que les gens qui sont
licenciés que nous notre diplôme reconnu
valoriser la coordination des
infirmières a par ailleurs renouvelé sa
demande d'entrevue au président de la
république
cette grogne des infirmières pourraient
faire tâche d'huile l'ensemble du
personnel de santé commencent à se
mobiliser
cet après midi il s'est réuni lui aussi
en coordination les infirmières réunis à
paris ont également décidé d'en appeler
directement au président de la
république qu'elle voudrait rencontrer
la semaine prochaine le chef de l'état
qui était aujourd'hui dans la région
lyonnaise a trouvé sur son passage
les signes de ce mécontentement social
des personnels hospitaliers des
fonctionnaires et les cheminots
également jean michel mercurol changer
la ville pour changer la vie
le thème que s'était assigné françois
mitterrand aujourd'hui en venant visiter
à oullins et villeurbanne deux
témoignages de la rénovation des
banlieues mais dans les deux villes
slogans et pancartes étaient là pour
l'accueillir ici des cheminots en colère
là la coordination des infirmières une
nouvelle occasion pour le chef de l'état
de prôner le dialogue social
j'entends - d'éloges que de critiques et
c'est bien normal je suis là pour ça il
faut bien que j'entende la plainte des
français quand ça va pas et là où ça va
pas il suffit d'entendre ce qui est
mehdi ce matin sur cette place pour
comprendre qu'il y à des fractions de la
population qu'il ya aussi des
travailleurs dans certains domaines et
d'une façon générale des problèmes
nationaux se retrouve partout où cela
doit être entendu tout cela doit être
discuté
aussitôt dit aussitôt fait le président
venant sa forme et lui même auprès des
syndicalistes
méfiez vous des dossiers soutient les
procès sont organisés via losc ce soir
quand je les range 8 joliton ans dont
elle restait le centenaire de l'école de
santé des armées à bron simple poignée
de main avec raymond barre mais là pas
le temps d'engager un quelconque
dialogue
voilà donc pour les faits aujourd'hui
notre invité ce soir c'est monsieur
claude evin le ministre de la solidarité
de la santé monsieur et 20 avant d'en
venir aux propositions qui ont été
refusées vous l'avez entendu tout à
l'heure dans le reportage
j'aimerais que vous nous parler un peu
de votre position ce soir d'un côté les
infirmières passe au dessus de vous on
s'en réfère directement chef de l'état
le chef de l'état comprend la plainte
des français 1017 au gouvernement de
gérer cette affaire
c'est en effet au gouvernement d'en
assumer la responsabilité je crois que
le président de la république l'a
lui-même confirmé et d'ailleurs depuis
quinze jours le gouvernement discute
écoute les infirmières il écoute les
organisations syndicales des coûts de la
coordination il écoute l'union des
associations lui nassif et j ai
personnellement passé beaucoup d'heures
jour nuit mon cabinet aussi nous avons
beaucoup écouté quand vous restez
l'interlocuteur je suis le ministre en
charge de ce dossier
c'est un dossier qui dépend plus de la
fonction publique hospitalière je suis
en responsabilité sur ce dossier en
effet alors revenons-en aux chiffres qui
ont été avancés
la revendication le rappel des
infirmières est de 1000 francs en
augmentation uniforme
vous vous proposez 595 points brut au
départ pour les infirmière débutante
augmentation 8% 764 francs pour une
infirmière au bout de six ans c'est à
dire 9 % d'augmentation et au terme de
15 ans 16% d'augmentation 1536 francs
est ce qu'on peut aller au delà de ça
dans la négociation je connais la
revendication des infirmières je connais
aussi leurs problèmes d'ailleurs je suis
moi-même président d'un conseil
d'administration d'un centre hospitalier
général à saint nazaire ça fait 14 ans
que je préside ce conseil
d'administration je connais bien ce
problème sur les salaires d'abord mais
il
le problème des salaires dans ce que
pose des infirmiers ères entendu preuve
du statut de je vais revenir tout à
l'heure elles ont un statut les
infirmières dans le cadre du statut de
la fonction publique hospitalière et les
propositions que nous avons reformulé
revalorise ce statut alors allé au delà
en matière de rémunération ce n'est pas
possible pourquoi c'est pas possible
c'est pas qu'on ne voudrait pas aller au
delà c'est que aller au delà se serait
payé les augmentations à monnaie de
singe ça veut dire qu'on prendrait le
risque que l'inflation mordent ces
augmentations et les infirmières elle
même n'y gagnerait pas et puis il ya les
autres salariés de la fonction publique
les autres salariés dans notre pays il
n'est pas possible de dérivés sur
l'ensemble des salaires voilà pourquoi
le gouvernement ne peut pas aller au
delà
alors je veux bien que dans votre
affaire la difficulté qu'il ya dans
cette affaire c'est que d'un côté vous
n'avez pas à faire là directement aux
syndicats mais une coordination et
est-ce que vous avez la possibilité de
négociations dans l'impression de de la
part des infirmiers une position sur
laquelle on ne transige pas comment
allez vous pouvoir vous sortir de cette
affaire c'est bien la difficulté de
négocier avec la coordination qui depuis
le début reste bloquée figé sur sa
position de 2000 francs une négociation
c'est la recherche d'un compromis et on
ne peut pas passer un compromis avec la
coordination qui est resté depuis le
départ sur les 2000 francs je souhaite
que l'on sorte le plus rapidement
possible de ce conflit mais il est
nécessaire de rapprocher les points de
vue et je constate que la coordination y
compris encore aujourd'hui et sur 2000
francs et que pouvez vous faire vous
pour tenter de rapprocher les points de
vue est ce que vous n'avez pas d'une
certaine façon au départ un peu négligé
cette coordination je n'ai pas du tout
des clichés cette coordination j'ai vu
beaucoup beaucoup vous avez reçu les
syndicats dans un premier temps vous ne
receviez que les syndicats non non non
non non non je rappelle que dès le
premier jour mon directeur de cabinet a
reçu la coordination régionale
ile-de-france le développement des
coordinations aujourd'hui si nous
assistions de nouveau à ce problème je
souhaite bien du courage à tous mes
collègues ministres ministre des ptt
ministre des transports avec la sncf ou
autre j'allais vous dire là il ya une
dépêche qui est tombé vers 19h20 le
comité national de liaison des cheminots
lance un appel à la mobilisation
générale entre le 17 et 21 octobre
on se retrouve dans un peu dans la
position de monsieur chirac
l'hiver 86 96 avec sexy coordination de
cheminots là encore on se retrouve avec
autre chose comme interlocuteur d'autres
personnes que les syndicalistes
oui ce problème ces coeurs pose de
graves questions au mouvement syndical
il lui appartient de le gérer de le
traiter
le gouvernement doit écouter le
gouvernement ils écoutent tous ceux qui
s'expriment j'ai écouté la coordination
j'y ai passé de nombreuses heures avec
la coordination depuis maintenant 15
jours
mais discuter arriver à un accord c'est
donc recherché ce sur quoi on peut
avancer ce sur quoi il n'est pas
possible d'avancer tournante discute
avec la coordination j'ai aussi discuté
ils m'ont dit beaucoup de choses ils ont
beaucoup exprimer ce qu'ils ressentent
ce que les actions bien ressenti c'est
un ras-le-bol c'est vrai et elles
attendent des réponses sur les salaires
je me suis exprimé sur la formation et
sur les conditions de travail
je les entends du tout à l'heure ce que
je voudrais dire sur la formation et sur
les conditions de travail
c'est que j'ai pris des engagements j'ai
pris les engagements que je tiendrais et
je ne peut pas résoudre ces problèmes en
huit jours parce que ce sont des
problèmes compliqués qui ne trouvent pas
de solution en huit jours mais
j'apporterai des réponses sur ces
problèmes qu'elles ont posé monsieur me
je vous remercie
la politique maintenant avec la décision
prise aujourd'hui par le rpr à propos du
référendum sur la nouvelle calédonie les
hommes politiques ont le sens de la
formule qui surprend au c'est hier il ya
eu le oui mais critique du l'udf qui
s'apparentait à une formule célèbre du
président giscard d'estaing aujourd'hui
l'appel du rpr non pas à l'abstention
banal simple mais à la non-participation
motivés et engagés cela dit la décision
n'a pas été facile à prendre et c'est
une nouveauté dans le mouvement
gaulliste on a voté à bulletins secrets
jean-louis le sait tout le monde devra
le respecter la loi démocratique
il s'applique au rassemblement pour la
cuvée
jacques chaban delmas qui on le sait
militait pour le oui au référendum devra
donc se plier lui même à la loi de la
démocratie interne
80 % des membres du comité central se
sont prononcés à bulletins secrets pour
l'abstention pardon pour la
non-participation engagés et motivés
selon la formule d'alain juppé il est
vrai que l'état major du rpr écartelée
entre les tenants du oui de michel noir
absent aujourd'hui à edouard balladur
présent 9% des suffrages et l'étonnant
du nom 11%
il est vrai que l'état major du rpr ne
pouvait pas ne pas proposer l'abstention
seulement paradoxe le rpr locale en
nouvelle calédonie s'est prononcé lui en
faveur du oui seulement paradoxe le
référendum est une procédure les gays
dans les institutions par le général de
gaulle
cette façon d'essayer de nous
culpabiliser en invoquant la mémoire du
général de gaulle dont personne ne
serait aujourd'hui ce qu'il aurait fait
face à ce scrutin est une manoeuvre qui
l'a aussi participent de l'opération
politicienne
c'est un choix courageux peu de ne pas
céder à la facilité de l'air ambiant ou
de la mode et de se déterminer en
fonction de ses propres convictions
notre conviction c'est que nous ne
pouvons pas répondre à cette question
truquée mis par winnie pardon et donc
c'est un engagement fort et motivés que
de refuser de participer en la question
de savoir si ces gaullistes ou pas
gaulliste forêt d'excellents arguments
pour vous dire en 1946 par exemple au
premier référendum constitutionnel de la
quatrième république le général de
gaulle n'avait pas pris position
le rpr fera donc campagne pour la non
participation
pendant ce temps l'udf fera campagne
pour le oui le oui mais et pourtant on
nous disait cette semaine encore que
l'udf et le rpr sur la nouvelle
calédonie procédait de la même analyse
au nom de l'union d'opposition et ce sur
ce sujet monsieur le pensec qui est le
ministre des territoires et départements
d'outre-mer affirme ce soir que la
non-participation du rpr est un
reniement du gaullisme ce que conteste
vous l'avez entendu monsieur juppé au
cours de ce voyage de françois
mitterrand dans la région lyonnaise
aujourd'hui que nous évoquions tout à
l'heure à propos la crise sociale
le président a fait une visite imprévue
à la famille de madame jacqueline
valente prise en otage sur un bateau au
large du
liban avec ses enfants en novembre 1987
est depuis un an maintenant
officiellement du moins on n'a plus
aucune nouvelle des ravisseurs et de
leurs otages pascal deschamps la famille
de jacqueline valente attendait ce geste
depuis près d'un an
il ya trois jours sa soeur et son
beau-frère écrivait à françois
mitterrand que représente 5 minutes dans
votre emploi du temps
cinq minutes face aux 341 jours de
détention de trois enfants le président
acceptait de les rencontrer
l'entrevue n'a pas duré longtemps mais
elle avait valeur de symbole on
regrettait sincèrement que le président
publication personne n'avait jamais
évoqué le nom de valente de ses trop
petite fille n'avait jamais évoqué le
les otages de cisco s'est déjà déjà
important pour nous c'est le président a
reconnu comme quoi jacqueline était
otage de ses enfants
bon maintenant pour les négociations en
sait avec certitude que le gouvernement
s'occupe entrevue symbole parce que
depuis leur mystérieux enlèvement à
bondues s'il qu au large des côtes du
liban en novembre 1987
jacqueline valente ses petites filles et
ses cinq amis belges n'avaient jamais
vraiment été considérés comme des otages
parce que depuis l'envoi de cassettes
vidéo au début de l'année c'est le
silence silence du côté des ravisseurs
silence du côté officiel alors même s'il
n'a pas pu donner à la famille des
informations sur la situation des otages
ou sur d'éventuelles négociations
le président de la république a en
quelque sorte aujourd'hui briser ce
silence société comment réduire le
nombre de détenus dans les prisons
françaises le ministère de la justice
prépare en ce moment même toute une
série de recommandations au juge
d'instruction car il faut savoir que sur
les plus de quarante mille détenus qui
se trouve incarcérés dans les prisons
françaises
vingt mille sont en détention préventive
attendant donc leur jugement
et cette détention n'est pas toujours
indispensable
thierry km
instruction en cours derrière les
barreaux vingt mille détenus provisoires
selon les termes de la loi en fait plus
du tiers des 44 mille prisonniers
français sont des présumés innocents en
attente de jugement pour changer cette
situation le garde des sceaux propose
trois mesures pour les mineurs d'abord
délai d'incarcération raccourcis le juge
d'instruction devra également motivé
c'est à dire expliqué par un acte
juridique sa décision de mettre une
personne en prison
autre préoccupation mieux connaître la
personnalité du prévenu celle enquête
rapide menée par les services du juge
d'instruction une mesure bien accueillie
par certains magistrats
l'anc et rapide qui nous permettra
d'avoir un maximum d'éléments sur la
personnalité et la situation d'inculpé
au moment de la prise de décision qui
peut déboucher sur une détention
provisoire et le faible de motiver cette
décision
il était évident que même en matière
criminelle nous expliquions pourquoi
l'inculpé aller en détention c'était
verbal donc ça ne changera pas
foncièrement la situation sur le banc de
la défense on est satisfait par les
recommandations de monsieur arpaillange
mais les avocats rappellent que la
détention provisoire ne devrait être
qu'une exception
il faut avant tout qu'il y ait une
véritable prise de conscience de
l'ensemble du corps judiciaire pour
redonner à la détention provisoire
le caractère exceptionnel que lui avait
donné le législateur en 1957
l'exception c'est la définition même de
ce qui ne doit pas se faire trop
quotidiennement la difficulté en matière
de détention provisoire c'est qu'elle
est bien souvent la règle et le fait de
ne pas aller en prison est bien trop
souvent l'exception le garde des sceaux
veut désengorger les prisons surpeuplées
mais ces recommandations au juge
d'instruction augmente aussi la
protection et les garanties du citoyen
face à la loi il a souhaité que ces
mesures soient rapidement mises en
application parmi l'avalanche de sondage
qui nous submerge quotidiennement tous
n'ont pas le même intérêt loin de là
mais celui-ci complétée par une enquête
du magazine 50 millions de consommateurs
est intéressant en effet ils indiquent
aujourd'hui en france un ménage sur
trois est endetté et le phénomène va en
empirant certains se trouvent
aujourd'hui obligés d'emprunter pour
rembourser les intérêts de l'ordre
raison première de l'endettement la
maison individuelle pascal de chant un
véritable cycle infernal
au début en
empreinte pour acheter et puis très vite
on emprunte pour rembourser l'emprunt
si l'anc est de 50 millions de
consommateurs tirent le signal d'alarmé
c'est que le surendettement peut
entraîner des situations dramatiques
comme celle d'un jeune couple de la
région d'orléans
endetté à 73% il a renoncé à avoir des
enfants
les responsables les emprunteurs bien
sûr pas toujours conscients du risque
mais aussi les organismes prêteurs qui
ont tout à gagner à pousser au près et
les vendeurs qui ont tout à gagner à
surestimer les ressources de leurs
clients résultat une véritable explosion
du crédit le montant des prêts a plus
que doublé en trois ans on achète tout à
crédit et pas seulement sa maison où sa
voiture
attention danger le remboursement des
emprunts absorbe aujourd'hui 6 % des
revenus des français deux fois plus
qu'il ya quatre ans les offres publiques
d'achat
les raids actuelle des financiers sur
les entreprises françaises et
européennes nous font oublier que
l'industrie n'est pas un ce prix mais
une course de fond l'industrie mécanique
française le sait qui va se réunir en
convention nationale la semaine
prochaine à paris pour marquer sa sortie
du tunnel après avoir été performante
dans les années 70 elle a connu une
certaine défaillance
mais aujourd'hui elle se replace en
position de leader en choisissant des
créneaux pointu et précis exemple eh
bien cette société que l'on peut
qualifier de joaillerie de la mécanique
puisqu'elle fabrique des moules de
pièces détachées autant d'objets uniques
destinés aux plus grandes sociétés
aéronautiques du monde jacques violet
fini les pièces de mécanique que l'on
fabrique dans cet atelier ressemblent
parfois à des sculptures modernes des
pièces uniques ouvrages et avec passion
et précision
le métier de modeleur commence après le
travail de l'ingénieur qui a conçu un
nouvel engin il s'agit de fabriquer les
moules pour couler des pièces qui
n'existe pas encore
ces hommes réalisent le moule d'une
pièce du moteur du futur airbus a340 qui
volera dans cinq ans des centaines de
pièces en dur à l'humain tourner fraiser
lee
mais ajusté assemblée elles permettront
de couler la pièce que ce soit avec des
robots ou des petit lim
on travaille au centième de millimètre
semoule outre environ un million et demi
de francs il faudra trois mille cinq
cents heures de travail pour le réaliser
c'est tout le savoir-faire de 45
employés et d'un patron jaloux de ses
techniques de son tour de main d'autres
jours lorsque les japonais sont venus
pour nous visiter je les ai obligé à
laisser leurs appareils
avant d'entrer dans l'entreprise la
seule autorisation je l'aurais donné
cette photographier le chat et comment
tout ça a commencé
ça a commencé par un certificat d'études
ap apprentissage sur le tas avec des
compagnons qui ne faisait pas de cadeau
le balayage de l'atelier puis la vente
des copeaux et puis à pourra faire une
mortaise à à tailler une tubulure dans
du bois et ensuite une expérience faite
dans toutes les petites boîtes de la
région et joueurs d'avoir une quinzaine
à mon actif aujourd'hui à 58 ans lojack
est connu partout en europe et aux états
unis surtout par les fabricants de
moteurs d'avions qui apprécient la
précision dans les bureaux
l'informatique permet de concevoir les
formes de visualiser la trajectoire des
outils plus loin on étudie un plan de
moteurs qui vient de chez rolls royce
c'est injuste heures fraser mode leur
parlent de leurs plus belles pièces avec
passion ici le moule d'une roue de
turbine du réacteur qui s'ouvre comme
une fleur pour pouvoir des moules et 50
pièces en bronze et acier tout fait à la
main le travail d'une pmi et de ses
hommes il n'existe plus en france que
trois ou quatre entreprises capables de
réaliser ces pièces rien à voir avec le
sujet précédent c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire dans le val d'oise la grande
banlieue parisienne où les monuments
moderne ressemble plus souvent
aujourd'hui à des supermarchés cas des
cathédrales vient on à renouer cet après
midi avec la tradition des calvaires
avec l'inauguration d'une statue de 7
mètres symbolisant la vierge et l'enfant
jean marc brami quarante mille fidèles
environ aujourd'hui dans la ville de
bail
en france pour accueillir notre dame de
france une vierge à l'enfant de plus de
7 mètres de hauteur
installer un carrefour de la route
nationale 1 et de la future autoroute
a16
cette statue dominera la plaine de
france une vierge qui couronnait le
pavillon pontificale de l'exposition
universelle de 1937 à paris et qui a
connu des fortunes diverses durant 50
ans désormais elle sera selon le voeu de
l'église catholique un symbole à
l'exemple des anciens calvaire qui
bordaient les routes
il fera vu de tout le passereau
carrefour jamais que c'est magnifique
vous pouvez que en 1988 installer encore
une statue alors on cherche plutôt des
conforama des choses comme ça chanteurra
sens ça démontre tout le peuple dira
unef démontre que la foi n'est pas
quelque chose de perdu jésus nous est
donnée par marie et que plein de
tendresse
le spirituel pour tous les hommes de
notre temps et spécialement tous ceux
qui vont passer sur la route puisqu'ils
vont être nous dit on quelques dizaines
de milliers des centaines de milliers
des millions prévoit ton et bien ce sera
un signe
un message de jean paul ii et la
bénédiction de monseigneur housset
évêque de pontoise clôturait une journée
où les fidèles ont exprimé leur foi avec
la ferveur qu'on leur connaît le sport
maintenant on en vient à alain prost à
quinze jours du grand prix de formule 1
du japon qui sera déterminant pour
l'attribution du titre de champion du
monde 88
le président de la fédération
internationale automobile monsieur jean
marie balestre écrit aujourd'hui aux
ingénieurs de la firme honda qui
fabrique le moteur de la mclaren d'alain
prost mais aussi du brésilien ayrton
senna son coéquipier pour leur dire de
veiller à laisser une chance égale aux
deux champions pourquoi cette
recommandation est à l'achat mais un mur
d'ordinateurs discrètement installé dans
un coin du stand une armée d'ingénieurs
et beaucoup de mystères à mystères qui
forcément encourage les supputations les
interrogations les rumeurs ce fabuleux
moteur v6 honda turbo qui dominent le
monde de la formule 1 est il le même
pour prost et senna
les japonais peuvent ils choisir leurs
vainqueurs en lui fournissant un
matériel plus compétitif est-ce que
ayrton senna et alain prost sont les
jouets d'une équipe d'ingénieurs au
service d'un jeu commercial considérable
ce sont des questions qui entourent une
saison exceptionnelle dans la mesure où
deux pilotes de la même équipe lutte
pour le titre mondial
un début d'année équilibrée plus une
domination de senna est maintenant une
domination de prost qui aurait poussé un
coup de gueule envers les japonais
il reste deux grands prix jean marie
balestre a demandé à honda de ne pas
être l' arbitre du duel mais est ce
vraiment possible
voilà notre invité ce soir comme promis
alain prost merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation va tout de suite parlé de
votre livre j'ai voulu également que
lionel chamoulaud qui vous suit tout au
long de l'année dans les courses de
formule 1 soit la première question
lionel c'est un petit peu la suite de ce
que l'on vient de voir est ce que les
japonais peuvent choisir s condat peut
choisir le pilote qui va être champion
du monde
j'ai pas la réponse à cette question je
pense pas honnêtement ce que je pensais
ce qui s'est passé depuis quelques
courses
est dû au fait que en premier mon style
de pilotage est complètement différent
de celui des retours sénat et que les
réglages de nos moteurs étant identiques
il convenait plus ou moins bien à l'un
ou à l'autre
ceci dit maintenant avec l'électronique
puisque vous savez tout est lié à
l'électronique je crois qu'il ya des
choses qui se passent qui ne sont pas
bien entendu de ma compétence et de
temps en temps ils sont un petit peu un
petit peu perdues j'ose pas croire que
que l'on a sciemment qui le facilement
ce que je pensais qu'il ya un moment de
la saison ils ont été peut-être un petit
peu moins soucieux de la préparation de
mon moteur et c'est pour ça que je
l'aurais dit avant mercredi portugal
parce que c'est important c'est que le
prochain grand prix a lieu au japon à
suzuka on sait que suzuka c'est honda
lance ce sont les usines mandat et une
victoire suffit à senna pour être
champions du monde ils prêts décidé que
le titre qui lui se jouer là bas au
japon se serait terminée je pense pas
qu'ils ont intérêt à privilégier d'abord
ayrton senna ou à jouer le le titre au
japon leur intérêt c'est de gagner au
japon faut pas oublier que l'année
dernière ils ont subi un affront qui
c'est c'est justement cet affront qui
leur fait penser qu'il faut absolument
gagner et pour gagner il faudra le
concours des deux pilotes c'est à dire
qu'il faudra que les deux pilotes et le
même matériel c'est ce que je pense tort
pour eux c'est plus important de gagner
au japon que éventuellement de
privilégier ayrton senna au risque dans
les mécaniques et et de l'essai par
exemple ferrari gagner comme l'année
dernière mais ce serait possible parce
que vous avez aujourd'hui avec la
technicité la sophistication ce serait
possible sion les 6 2 vraiment on veut
pas je veux pas jouer sur les mots mais
je pense qu'avec justement
l'électronique
il ne maîtrise pas tous les problèmes
c'est ce que je veux dire bien alors on
va remous revenir à votre livre alain
prost maître de mon destin à un monde
plus pur d'abord celui de l'enfance donc
dans ce livre est édité chez michel
lafon
vous nous dites au début d'abord vous
nous montrez s'ouvrait qu'on montre bien
à l'écran pour la première fois sans
doute c'est un scoop on voit votre
permis de conduire
alors j'aurai qu'on le voit voilà permis
de conduire saint-chamond alain mari
pascal praud ce 24 février 55 ça c'est
votre date de naissance et vous avez eu
votre permis le cese 4,73 délivrée par
la préfecture de la loire et alors on ne
peut pas dire qu'on vous ait vraiment
poussé dans la carrière va votre famille
à l'impasse que la jolie à la page 25
je me souviens d'un beau jour où j'en ai
ma mère' à lyon dans la voiture
familiale devait rouler assez vite et
prendre les trajectoires qui lui des
pelures fortement elle m'invite à
fermement
m'arrêter à lui rendre le volant au bout
d'un certain nombre de fois où elle
m'avait dit fred ne colle pas freine
donc avait pas une confiance excessive
et c'est justement tout l'intérêt de ce
livre à mon avis est que j'ai pas voulu
faire un livre un peu limite pour
raconter des histoires qui sont passées
dans le milieu de la formule il y en a
bien entendu et c'est moi qui ai choisi
le titre d'ailleurs c'est pour moi qui
l'ait écrit il faut le dire tout de
suite il a absolument aucune ambiguïté
mais c'est un livre qui retrace ma vie à
une certaine époque et bien entendu ma
carrière et pour expliquer un petit peu
aussi aux gens justement à travers que
j'étais pas mis un surhomme et que
j'étais pas du tout prédestiné à être
pilote automobile puisque dans ma
famille est actuellement aucun aucune
terre cela lord touchés de près ou de
loin ce milieu dans ce livre alain il y
a beaucoup de souvenirs très précis
alors lionel va goûter c'était un pari
que vous avez une mémoire infaillible de
toutes les courses que vous avez fait et
là on se rend bien compte dans livre
vous nous raconter comment dentelle
cours vous avait crevé un pneu et c'est
direct va faire un petit test l'arrêt
c'est vrai qu'elle a écrit ce livre avec
jean louis moncet je voulais vous poser
les questions pour rédiger après un
toutou se livre alors sur votre carrière
par le nombre de tours que vous avez
fait
en tête sont très divisés je sais que
j'ai fait à peu près aux alentours de 7
mille et quelques kilomètres 7500
kilomètres en tête je sais pas combien
de salles représente deux tours sans
faux fuyants 772 toujours ça vous le
saviez pas par exemple enfin vous avez
plein de records vous adorez les records
de dorer les statistiques le nombre de
points que vous avez marqué 4 196 8 598
me voir moi je viens simplement vous
avez été deux fois champion du monde et
vous avez gagné 34 du grand prix jamais
personne n'avait gagné autant un an leur
aide le second est donc jackie stewart
maintenant evans alors il ya une phrase
aussi là que vous que kick est
importante parce qu'elle est d'actualité
dans les écuries de formule 1 le rival
le plus direct il plus dangereux c'est
votre équipier qui devait plupart du
temps à la même voiture et qui joue pour
vous le rôle impitoyable de mieux miroir
alors ce moment à ayrton senna c'est
votre principal adversaire pour laisser
le problème que qu'on a tous mais
entendu puisque c'est les médias qui
sont là c'est la presse le public et où
il regarde en fonction des du matériel
là le meilleur moyen de juger un pilote
c'est de juger au travers de son équipe
puisqu'il est art mega normalement avec
l'autre pilote
c'est ce qui est difficile pour moi
puisque bondir comme senna 28 ans et n'a
jamais été champion du monde et moi j'en
ai trente troisième livre à vous
entendre
non je lui ainsi s'il rapporte ou là on
a des très bons rapports ce que je veux
dire parce que ça me rappelle une phrase
dans notre métier on dit dans le
journalisme c'est pierre lazareff qui
disent ça tellement on s'aime lorsqu on
s'embrasse et jusqu'à s'étouffer est ce
que c'est la même chose dans le sport je
pense qu'il y à il ya très très peu de
pilotes qui s'entendent bien dans la
même équipe je crois que c'est dû au
fait qu'il ya trop d'intérêts ya trop de
problèmes et ce que je voulais dire
surtout c'est qu'on n'est jamais égalité
même avec la même voiture
ça paraît évident si fin du jour venait
maintenant mais chez mac line c'est
exactement le problème que quand tous
les pilotes
un jour on est on est très bien pendant
une saison où une mia elle une dernière
confiance dans la qualité puisque cette
semaine avec ayrton senna vous avez
essayé le nouveau moteur honda le v10
atmosphérique qui sera donc le prochain
moteur est ce que l'équipe mclaren avec
le nouveau moteur honda va dominer
autant la saison prochaine que delà de
1000 cette saison
un petit scoop c'est un moteur qui
marche aussi bien sinon mieux déjà que
le moteur turbo de cette année ce qui
veut dire que c'est un moteur d'une
nouvelle génération
notre atmosphérique et que ça va donner
beaucoup de fil à retordre à nos dollars
durant l'année prochaine dernière
question à la haye ce qu'on a on dit que
parfois vous n'êtes pas très aimable
certains disent même que vous avez la
grosse tête mais vous vous dites vous
avez une phrase qui veut montrer que
vous n'avez pas la grosse tête
parfois quand je joue au golf mal
d'ailleurs quand je rate des couffins si
je suis le premier à dire tout je suis
petit lait est con oui parce que c'est
mon et maladroit c'est mon humour je
pense à avoir quand même assez d'humour
pour justement je pense aussi que
personne peut dire que j'ai la grosse
tête je crois que si j'ai une des
qualités indépendamment de toutes celles
qui font le sel de pilote automobile
c'est justement que j'ai pas la grosse
tête et point c'est fou merci à la en
tout cas je rappelle donc le titre de
votre livre alain prost maître de mon
destin aux éditions michel lafon merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce soir on va
en rester là pour l'actualité de ce jour
elle était largement bien fourni
peut-être je le temps de vous rappeler
les pronostics du tiercé pour demain si
on laisse le temps de les passer on va
les inscrire sur l'écran non je voulais
rappelle envoie le 7 le 12 le 15 mai
voici on obéit en plus le 3 le 8 le 1 le
6 et le 10 et je vous rappelle que
maintenant vous retrouvez à 19h30 tous
les samedis soirs piret de bresse pour
ses pronostics
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après le journal la météo et puis
en fin de programme vous retrouverez et
avec l'eau merci de votre fidélité à
demain 13h pourquoi
à